aujourd'hui une entente entériné par un
juge c'était en novembre 2014
le ministre de l'éducation était fier
d'annoncer une entente avec la seule
école illégal hassidique contre laquelle
les autorités avaient intenté des
procédures judiciaires
les garçons qui fréquentent l'école tu
auras ce marché devaient désormais
étudier le programme du ministère à la
maison un enseignement supervisé par la
commission scolaire english 28 ior
auprès d'un an plus tard les choses
commencent à peine à se mettre en branle
on est devant une fois on va faire tout
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour aider
dans qu'est ce que notre responsabilité
mais il va falloir que c'est sûr qu'à la
fin on a des évaluations qui nous
démontre que les jeunes sont très cons
peut mettre notre sueur dessus
cette affaire survient alors que le
problème des écoles hassidiques illégal
demeure quasiment entiers et ce malgré
les divers engagements de politiciens à
régler la question
on souhaite toujours que les enfants
soient scolarisés pour respecter la loi
ce serait que nos matières obligatoires
sont enseignés dans ces écoles il y en
auto leurs propres les écoles illégales
à outremont les écoles des trois grands
groupes hassidique n'ont toujours pas de
permis pour l'année scolaire en cours
dans côte-des-neiges
le ministère nous répond que le collège
rabbinique du canada a cessé ses
activités en septembre 2013
pourtant nous y sommes allés hier et
l'école est ouverte à boisbriand dans la
communauté tosh le permis de l'école
pour filles a été révoqué en 2013
l'école de garçons n'apparait même plus
dans les rapports des centaines de
garçons et de filles
ils sont pourtant scolarisés selon
l'article 1 de la loi sur l'enseignement
public tout enfants entre 6 et 18 ans au
québec a le droit de recevoir une
instruction conforme au régime
pédagogique établi par le ministère de
l'éducation le ministre françois blais
n'était pas disponible pour répondre à
nos questions émilie dubreuil radio
canada montréal